what up guys welcome to the Des early
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start like the
video on your way in and get yourself a
women sh F t-shirt to support the
channel and move that Overton window to
normalize getting rid of women's rights
yes okay so today I'm going to be
reacting to a delusional female
influencer saying that men are weaker I
would like to preface and say I am a
female athlete I play volleyball here in
England I had the opportunity to go pro
last year but I just decided to not do
that and do YouTube instead I have
played volleyball basketball ran track I
even did lacrosse at one point and
soccer I've done every sport and I can
attest and say no no no no men are
definitely stronger definitely but let's
let's see what she says let's see men
are weak they skap leg day because they
can't handle the pain we carry a hum oh
no oh Jesus for 9 months we get cramps
every single month so we still manage
why are women fatter like to three three
times a week can we stop acting like our
period is like a godsend like can we
stop act like all right guys I get it we
get our periods half of us are having
one kid like most of us are having one
to two children that's two years of Our
Lives not even and yet we want we want
everybody to like worship us I mean dogs
give birth I'm not trying to be rude but
like do we worship female dogs because
they give birth man train like a
woman yeah are you serious yeah if
you're a man and you're not training leg
day like a woman you're weak you're
pathetic you a [__] and MC bit and
obviously because women get period I
like this guy the Aran TV very based
very based guy every month and have to
go through child birth they're a lot
stronger than us biological advantages
don't make any difference what are they
this is why she's got over half a
million people following her and taking
her advice about Fitness cuz she knows
exactly what she's half these half these
chicks are on drugs anyway that's what I
found out so many female influencers
take like testosterone and all that
stuff you'd be surprised about are you
natural or not oh please don't lie
please am I natural or not that's for
you
guys all right this is getting
ridiculous to find
out I'm not even convinced that's a
woman so just guess huh take a wild
guess what I don't know what they're
going to say well unless you tell them
no I'm I'm not I'm natural you're
natural yeah lifetime this is getting so
sad boy look at her forehead there's
nothing natural about this chick natural
yes why the [__] you lying why you
always lying how do you think I keep my
face so lifetime natural and what
division you compete in bodybuilding
okay so men or sorry women's
bodybuilding yes why is he even asking
this question it's obvious that it's
natural just look is that a
dude check the mic is not hot enough I'm
sorry chica I I've seen women that
actually do get stared at when they work
out all the time because they're so
incredibly beautiful it's not you I'm
sorry don't don't I'm not like yeah look
I mean they're rare to be honest most
guys like they'll look and then they'll
kind of do their workout but usually
they look because you're wearing like
leggings you're like I like it's like
women we wear these [__] outfits and I
know the girls will come in and they'll
say oh that's not [__] they're
leggings I mean ask any guy they they
they view these leggings as revealing
make sure it sound right
boy someone said no one's staring at you
Squidward where oh she was wearing
leggings so all right all right you win
that one you win Express how completely
unsafe I feel at this gym now the way
she stops in stairs I felt uncomfortable
and unsafe it's out egregious
Preposterous oh and you know that's how
ridiculous we sound we go through life
not realizing how stupid we sound I hate
when people walk front of the camera on
purpose
it's too heavy for
me you doing it on purpose I swear to
God this guy doing it on
purpose the H I think he's I don't think
he's serious I think he's making fun of
women what's wrong with him what no
there's a Tik Tok right here down on Tik
Tok he he's he's going on Tik Tok right
now what an absolute donut not only for
Oh I thought he was kidding oh this guy
was serious Los Angeles I think people
are I think we have a low level of
mental illness right now that but for
posting this and thinking people would
take his side when he just got ripped
congratulations you played yourself
what's most disappointing about this
video is you say at the end I really
thought he was kidding this is going on
Tik Tok as if you're looking for
something to get upset about just so you
can post it on social media for some
clout I'm sorry but you don't get to set
your phone up across the this guy is
like the CEO of calling out Jim this guy
he he's like the internet Watchdog he's
like oh is that bad gy behavior I'm here
I'm ready then act like that space is
yours and nobody can walk by news flash
you don't own the gym and if somebody
happens to walk by through your video
too
[Music]
bad
the first time she ever saw a gym was on
Tik Tok and now she's entered one she's
realized [__] people actually work out
they don't just stand there and film
themselves like me plv you tell people
when they're in the frame excuse me do
you know how I'm filming this way do you
mind being in the frame cool yeah
P oh no you can stay no no
no by the way just so you know I'm
filming this way I no no no I don't mind
I don't mind I'm going saying like do
you mind all right well why I'm going to
ruin your video Oh no you're don't going
to ruin it it's
okay yeah that was a bit
[Laughter]
nice oh that is so
[Music]
funny fellas I've said it before but
your life's going to be a lot easier if
you get a woman with a sense of humor
I've been with women before that take
themselves way too serious and they're
usually a pain in the ass gym culture is
cringe ever since late 2022 gyms have
been absolutely atrocious you got dudes
working out in Corny mask you got dudes
out here acting like they're anime
villains and then you also got women out
here calling dudes creeps for literally
no reason at all the gym went from being
about I really think they should just
have a male only gym that women are
banned from but it's so funny the web
would would probably find a way to get
jobs like cleaning it or something
whenever there's a male own only space
women like we find a way to get in I
don't know what it is about us hard work
discipline and respect but now it's all
about ego clout and greed and it's
honestly getting annoying he ain't lying
yeah he's not wrong it went from hard
work discipline respect to a bunch of
corny Muppets acting on Tik Tok now me
personally if you want to make a little
Tik Tok looking like an anime villain
I'm not going to join you but if you're
not doing no harm go ahead and do it
especially if you're getting in shape at
the same time it's when these people
start lying or trying to make out other
people a perverse that's what bothers me
and in general I think the cameras in
the gym are annoying but there's a lot
of influencers that I have seen are
pretty decent and inspired a lot of
younger guys to get in the gym because
of their content so I'm not completely
against
[Music]
it
perfect a I feel bad for the guy I mean
she signed up what else is he supposed
to do but now you can tell he kind kind
of feels
bad see this guy he took the first
woman's advice and he trained leg day
like a woman be a man and try and like
that like a woman after 20 years
scientists have finished mapping the
entire Human Genome and scientists say
in this Gene right here we can see what
made you into such a little
[Laughter]
[Music]
[__] guys are so funny they are so much
funnier than chick I don't think you
have the facilities for that big man to
have a genuine question for all men all
active men I should
say if I'd slept with like say 20 men
would you be bothered here we go again
yes you would be bothered this is the
new Cheyenne Reynolds I would wouldn't
entertain you why because your body
counts 20 you know over 20 over 20
bodies as a chick you have an 80% chance
of cheating 80% chance 20 a whole mon
whole old people yeah lost their mind
but what if she had a bad past but these
were all from the past like young stupid
and now she is Untouchable but she just
has 20 b she's not Untouchable she she
is now though you can't just decide to
be Untouchable hold your horses there
bro it's 2023 near 2024 if I want to
wake up tomorrow and decide that I'm a
woman or a cat I can do that if she
wants to decide yeah you look it God can
forgive you but men don't have to and
I'll say it again God can forgive you
but men do not have to she's got zero
bodies after being with 20 she can do
that then you're going to put three oz
of bourbon in are you sure about that so
this is a pretty strong
drink wow and not that many people order
it and you rate me on a scale wow okay
now this chick wants to get raided so
I'm going to raid her out of the
kindness of my heart um six five six
right it's tough they have on all this
makeup up all right what king what do
you say wow our stuff is so off I said 5
six men and women rate so differently 1
to 10 four he says eight King said eight
this guy said four a girl that has an
only fans never I mean I like some nasty
but n $5,000 or one night with me see
this chick I would have given an eight
this chick You' say this is a six the
five
b that's hard I don't like rejection I
mean 5k is a lot of money uh 35 this or
a slap nah I'm married you married I'm
married slap it's just a slap I'm
married you
sure all right now [__] off I'm actually
convinced that all of these only fans
Tik Tok girls that ask these dumbass
questions are all NPCs that come from
the same government facility I basically
think they're a government experiment
that went completely wrong and now
they're just out in the wild Mal
functioning asking dumbass
questions
[Music]
obese is the nword for plus-size
people I I I think I'm speechless guys
every day I'm shocked by the level of
stupidity we have in this Society obese
please I was humbled so quick tonight I
was on live with my boyfriend and
someone was like how old's your
girlfriend and John jokingly responds 47
and the girl comments Oh I thought she
was early
30s I am 23 what life will humble you
man I honestly think a lot of these like
procedures make chicks look older like
you could tell she's at the botox the
work like you could see it I think that
stuff ages you I ain't even taking a
piss on this one she definitely looks
closer to early 30s and she does early
20s and everyone in the comments said
the same thing we need to stop beating L
men what would you rate her what I was
going to say four we're on the same page
with this one oh my
God guys are so funny why she think she
can
say
oh man I like to make music that moves
people clap clap clap clap clap that ass
B tell let me see put turn that [__] off
[Music]
11 years later but you in my 20s I would
not have thought that I would be single
in dating at 41 nice shots I think those
are different chicks but but you do see
the lifespan of like women now I'm sure
there's a lot of you watching this that
are into business and want to know what
good Investments to make for the future
cat food wine dog food you invest in
cats cuz cats are going to be in high
demand in 10 years these women are going
to be fighting for cats and I don't even
know if the cats are going to want to go
with them I think we're actually going
to have to decide who gets the cats how
much does a guy have to make to date you
at least like 200,000 a year 200 what
would you raid her wait let's do it at
the same time okay three two one four he
said three I was thinking three but yeah
okay but I don't know I was like maybe
four anyways now we have fours you know
let's let's average it me and King King
says three I said four 3.5s asking for
200k a year wow that's crazy I don't
even think women know how to add like
that that's the funny thing do you
really think every guy that this girl
has entertained has been making 200k
what she looks I'm not going to say that
God damn all right so what do what do
you think they they job going to be
being
200k probably some with computers
engineering look at her face she is dead
ass serious she really thinks that she's
going to get a man that earns 200,000 a
year not going to happen no not going to
happen I want to look at the numbers of
the guy is making these incomes what
jobs are they I would guess in the US
would be doctors or some sort of medical
I would guess engineering is more around
100K like late like 75 to 150 what I
don't think content creators are going
to be a top like obviously content
creators make a lot of money but I I
don't think that's going to be the
majority of of the men in the like if
you took a hundred people that make 100K
and up I wouldn't guess content creators
would be in the top I don't know they
might they might I want to go a bed with
you you need to give me a kiss so what
did you think about giving that guy a
kiss I have a
boyfriend no I said I wasn't single are
you single yes ever I wow I love you
that's crazy it's an evil world we live
in biggest when it comes to men um sassy
that blocked me because why the are you
blocking me you can't take what I'm
dishing out what did you dish out um a
lot like if I call your mother a you
should accept the fact that she's a not
rocket signs for this one I sometimes I
think these chicks are are trolling I'm
like why are you guys calling someone's
mother a [__] this one is it fellas if
she's got no eyebrows and she calls your
m a [__] she belongs to the
street yeah I these compilations are
funny funny this is the thing social
media like I think there was a point
where we understood the difference
between social media and real life or
you would see stuff on TV and you would
know you know that's celebrity land
that's not real life but social media
has really given us chicks the
impression that social media and the
guys we see on social media and us with
the filters on and the way we look on
social media is real life it it's just
not the case guys most people are
average most people will be with and
marry average people and if you don't
like it cry about it let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time